Hey guys, Jan here!
I hope you've had a chance to watch Daredevil
Season 2!
Just like season 1, I really enjoyed it and
loved Jon Bernthal's Punisher and Elodie Yung's
Elektra.
There were so many cool storylines explored
and lots of teases to possible future characters
and plot lines left open for the future.
So, I wanted to look at 7 things I really
want to see in Daredevil Season 3 and future
Marvel Netflix shows!
And spoiler warning: if you haven't finished
Daredevil Season 2 yet, make sure you come
back after you have, or you can check out
my spoiler-free review here!
With that very cool closing shot in the season
2 finale, it seems almost guaranteed that
we'll see Elektra revived by The Hand, but
I'm wondering in what form she's going to
come back.
In the comics, when the Hand goes to resurrect
Elektra, it orders its ninjas to give their
blood for her, and in the TV show we had the
kidnapped children being tapped for their
blood.
I'd love to see if Elektra will be used as
a kind of host for the Beast which is what
the Hand might have been digging for with
that huge hole in the middle of Manhattan.
In the comics, The Beast is a an ancient demon
that The Hand worships and in the Shadowland
story arc Daredevil becomes possessed by The
Beast so doing the same with Elektra on the
TV show could be a cool twist.
Melvin Potter, Daredevil's costumer, has had
some great scenes so far and both Daredevil
seasons have teased Potter's alter-ego Gladiator
from the comics with tons of easter eggs scattered
around his workshop.
There's the gladiators movie poster, the circular
saws that Gladiator uses as weapons, the blueprints
for a new costume, and Melvin's tease of his
classic Gladiator symbol which he revealed
to Matt in season 2.
There was also a hint to Gladiator ally Leap
Frog with a Giant Frogs poster in his workshop.
In the comics, Gladiator has been both an
ally and villain of Daredevil's.
So far in the show, he seems to like Daredevil's
work and is on his side.
But there's been mention before that he's
worked for criminals and those Stilt-Man legs
and armour have been teased heavily in both
seasons, so it would be awesome to see someone
like Turk become Stilt-Man, which he once
did in the comics.
Jon Bernthal's portrayal of the Punisher was
incredible in season 2.
The finale also cemented his character and
mindset.
He's cut himself off completely from his old
life burning down his family home and declaring
himself already dead to Karen.
What I really want to see though is for Castle
to use that minigun which I think he will
as did you notice how his hand twitched in
the scene where he uncovers the weapons cache
and the camera focuses on the minigun?!
There was also a nice tease for Castle's assistant
Microchip from the comics with the Micro disc
that Castle recovers from his old home.
By the way, Micro was namedropped in an episode
of Agents of SHIELD and described as a kind
of "crime scene junkie", providing intel to
Skye.
A team-up with Castle's brutal killing skills
and a computer hacker like Microchip would
be an awesome combo to see on Daredevil, a
Punisher spin-off or any other Marvel shows.
Wilson Fisk promised Matt Murdock that he
would come after Matt and Foggy when he gets
out of prison.
Although Fisk was only in season 2 for a small
part, he really made his presence felt when
he did appear and Vincent D'Onofrio played
the crime lord so well that I really want
to see him back again.
It was pretty terrifying when he smacked Matt
down after Matt threatened to take Vanessa
away from him, and I can't wait to see what
evil plans he has in store for the Avocado
At Law.
By the way, in the Born Again comic story
arc, Karen Page, who's become a drug addict,
sells the information that the identity of
Daredevil is Matt Murdock.
This info eventually reaches the Kingpin who
sets about destroying Matt's life.
It would be cool to see how the TV show might
tackle this storyline.
We've had some sneaky teases to Bullseye in
both Daredevil seasons.
The sniper who worked for Fisk in the first
season had a playing card in his gun bag and
the Metro General hospital coffee cups in
season 2 had playing card designs on them.
Bullseye often used playing cards as weapons
in the comics and has a long history of antagonism
with Daredevil.
He was once hired by Maxwell Glenn to kill
Matt Murdock and Foggy Nelson and given that
the sniper with the playing card in season
1 was under Fisk's control, it's easy to see
that Bullseye could be brought in as a supervillain
for season 3.
Karen Page has a chequered history in the
comics and the TV show has hinted at a similarly
complex background for her in the MCU.
We got the first full tease of this in the
second season when we finally glimpsed what
was in the file journalist Ben Urich was keeping
on her.
The newspaper cutting in the file has a headline
"Mystery Accident Causes Teen Fatality" and
makes mention of a "young man, Kevin Paxton
Page, of Fagan Corners" who died in a car
accident for unknown reasons.
The cutting also mentions a man with a grey
military moustache, a girl of eight or nine
crying, and a brother.
The girl is probably Karen and although there's
no record of her having a brother in the comics,
her father is called Paxton Page and he was
a scientist who was exposed to cobalt radiation
and became the Daredevil villain Death's Head.
I don't think we'll see Death's Head appear
on the TV show, but the series is definitely
hinting at a bigger storyline to explore here.
I really enjoyed the Jessica Jones tie-in
with Foggy being offered a job by Jeri Hogarth
to help her law firm with cases involving
super-powered individuals like Jessica Jones.
I think it could be a cool way to get Foggy
teaming up with Jessica Jones herself.
And a final bonus thing I'd love to see would
be an Avengers cameo on the show, for example,
what about Tom Holland coming in as Spider-Man?
I mean, wouldn't that be awesome?!
I'm not sure the MCU is still quite ready
to fully integrate the movie and TV universes
in that way yet, but it would be so cool if
they could make it happen at some point!
So guys, what would you love to see in Daredevil
Season 3, The Defenders, or any of Marvel's
other shows on Netflix?
And what did you most enjoy about Season 2?
Do let me know in the comments below.
And if you're a fan of Daredevil, I've got
some great Daredevil collectibles to give
away on my Top 5 WTF moments from Season 2
and my full review of all the easter eggs
and references in the series.
So, check them out!
And if you enjoyed this video, make sure you
subscribe for more comic book movie and TV
videos coming shortly on Batman V Superman
and next month Captain America: Civil War.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, superhero lovers!